[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
de kobe 19 y a continuación algunos de
los temas que vamos a tener en el
programa de hoy
hablaremos de las recientes medidas
adoptadas por las autoridades del estado
de nueva york en eeuu de levantar el
mandato del uso obligatorio de
mascarillas en los espacios cerrados una
medida que ha generado todo tipo de
reacciones entre especialistas
ciudadanos y empresarios tenemos
reportes desde la ciudad de nueva york
para conocer más detalles sobre esta
medida en nuestra consulta con el doctor
pérez nuestro médico y asesor médico y
científico analizaremos precisamente las
condiciones necesarias para levantar
estas restricciones como el uso de las
mascarillas esto ante la posibilidad de
que en américa latina' sean adoptadas
medidas similares a las que hemos
anunciado en la ciudad de nueva york
también hablaremos del corona dengue la
mezcla de estas dos dolencias que ya
están presentes en algunas regiones de
nuestro continente y por último daremos
un vistazo a la situación en chile un
país en donde ya fue puesta a la
inoculación de la cuarta dosis para
personas mayores de 55 años este país
también enfrenta un repunte en el número
de personas hospitalizadas en salas de
cuidados intensivos a esta cifra también
va ligado el aumento en el número de
fallecidos en ese país suramericano
muy bien pues empezamos el programa lo
hacemos como siempre con un vistazo a
las cifras de cómo está avanzando la
pandemia de kobe 19 en nuestro
continente de acuerdo al conteo que
adelanta la universidad johns hopkins
comenzamos en belice allí los casos ya
superan los 54 mil 900 mientras que los
fallecidos superan los 600 seguimos allí
en centroamérica costa rica reporta para
el cierre de esta semana más de 751 mil
casos de contagio y más de 7.700
personas han fallecido la vecina panamá
termina esta semana con más de 730 mil
casos y más de 7 mil 900 personas han
fallecido ya se aproximan a las 8000
víctimas mortales desde el inicio de la
emergencia sanitaria en ese país
saludamos a esta hora el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez médico infectólogo y
asesor científico de france 24 ya está
con nosotros para nuestra habitual
consulta doctor bienvenido al programa
como siempre un gusto y quiero comenzar
preguntándole por esas medidas que van a
adoptar en el estado de nueva york que
levantar la obligatoriedad de usar
mascarilla en los espacios cerrados qué
condiciones deben reunir las ciudades o
los estados para poder contemplar estas
medidas
santiago es muy importante entender que
estas medidas se toman cuando hay un
nivel de transmisión que ha disminuido
es decir que la positividad de la prueba
va a ir a bajado por lo menos por debajo
del 10% y que donde la mayoría de
población no solamente está vacunada
sino vacunada con refuerzo este tipo de
medidas son transitorias
deben ser evaluadas en el tiempo pero
paulatinamente vamos a retornar a esa
normalidad de retirar los tapabocas pero
depende mucho la inmunización y la
positividad que tenga la prueba en las
regiones geográficas donde se va a tomar
estas decisiones doctor vemos también
los casos del reino unido y de dinamarca
que son algunos de los países europeos
que han comenzado a levantar las
restricciones no solamente el uso de
mascarillas sino todo tipo de
restricciones en cierta forma europa ha
servido como espejo para el continente
americano esto quiere decir que en los
próximos meses américa podría estar
también
comenzando a levantar las restricciones
y volviendo prácticamente a la vida
normal que piensa usted
si es probable que paulista
y el que determinaría y la positivista
bueno tenemos problemas otra vez con la
señal con la señal del doctor para poder
terminar esta consulta y preguntarle
sobre los otros temas que teníamos para
preguntarle vamos a tratar de mejorar la
conexión mientras tanto vamos a avanzar
con otros temas que tenemos para el
programa hablamos entonces de la
variante omicron que ya representa cerca
del 96 7 por ciento de todas las
secuencias genéticas de coronavirus
realizadas en el último mes los expertos
señalan que en los lugares donde se
detectó esta variante en una fase
temprana la tendencia de contagios ya va
a la baja sin embargo los decesos han
ido aumentando a nivel global como lo
estábamos preguntando al doctor pérez le
damos el panorama mundial en el informe
de ariana villacorta
mientras los contagios por kobe 19
bajaron un 17% a nivel mundial las
muertes aumentaron en un 7% según un
informe epidemiológico realizado por la
organización mundial de la salud el
mismo estudio determinó que las regiones
del mediterráneo oriental y las américas
fueron las que más contagios se
registraron con un alza de 36% en ambos
casos mientras que europa registró un
incremento de un 7 por ciento
respecto a los decesos aumentaron en un
67% en la región del sudeste asiático
mientras que en europa y las américas se
mantuvo estable y se redujo en áfrica en
un 14% eeuu fue el país que más muertes
registró más de 96.000 seguido por india
rusia brasil y méjico
dependiendo de donde vivas puede parecer
que la pandemia de kobe 19 casi ha
terminado o puede parecer que está en su
peor momento pero dondequiera que viva
el kobe 19 no ha terminado con nosotros
las enfermedades no conocen fronteras
todos sabemos por micrón que cualquier
sentimiento de seguridad puede cambiar
de un momento a otro sabemos que este
virus seguirá evolucionando of soft y
con change in a moment
we know this waltz will continue to
world el continente con la tasa de
vacunación más alta en el mundo es
américa y aplicó más de mil 613 millones
de dosis de vacunas sin embargo caricia
detiene la directora de la organización
panamericana de la salud reveló que
mientras hay 14 países con un 70% de la
población inoculada con el esquema
completo el resto no logra alcanzar el
40% de vacunación de sus habitantes but
we are not defense less
we are de tours to prevent desde ces
pero no estamos indefensos tenemos las
herramientas para prevenir esta
enfermedad para detectarla y para
tratarlas cuando las personas tienen
acceso a estas herramientas este virus
puede controlarse donde no lo tienen
este virus continúa propagándose
evolucionando y mata no eres contiene
este sprint tribal
trucción en efecto lado ms instó a los
países de altos ingresos a brindar apoyo
financiero a través del acelerador de
acceso a herramientas kobe 19 una
iniciativa creada en 2020 para los
países en desarrollo con el objetivo de
mejorar la distribución de vacunas
tratamientos pruebas y otras
herramientas contra la enfermedad
raimon which they como se describe en el
marco de financiamiento que estamos
lanzando hoy el acelerador act requiere
23.000 millones de dólares
estadounidenses para salvar vidas
abordar la amenaza de omicron y evitar
que surjan variantes aún más peligrosas
eso incluye una brecha financiera
urgente de 16.000 millones de dólares
americanos para el propio acelerador act
con los 6.500 millones de dólares
restantes para hacer auto financiados
por los países de medianos ingresos con
el apoyo de los bancos multilaterales de
desarrollo bid en medellín con countries
sporting by multilateral development
banks
con el dinero solicitado el acelerador
act se proyecta a adquirir 600 millones
de vacunas 700 millones de pruebas de
diagnóstico tratar a 120 millones de
pacientes y ofrecer equipos de
protección para 17 millones de
trabajadores sanitarios
especialmente en los países con redes
sanitarias más frágiles
y continuamos nuestra consulta con el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez hemos
restablecido la conexión con el doctor
hablamos ahora por línea telefónica y
quiero preguntarle ahora por esos
estudios que ha publicado a lo largo de
esta semana que indican que la cuarta
dosis de una vacuna contra el jove 19
provoca una sobreestimulación del
sistema inmune qué tan cierto es esto y
qué significa esto para nuestros
organismos
santiago hay que tener en cuenta que la
dosis de las vacunas no se deben hacer
por capricho sino por los estudios
clínicos cuando se colocan múltiples
dosis de una vacuna hay un fenómeno
llamáis farc y game oncológica es decir
que existe ningún tuviera no reconocer
ya el antígeno de alimento con de que
queremos pelear por eso esta cuarta
dosis debe ser analizada no para tomar
una decisión de vacunarse en 46 min sino
tener un estatus vacunal es decir que
también estamos inmunizados y sobre todo
esta cuarta dosis va a ser muy
importante en poblaciones especiales
trasplantados personas con cáncer o con
deficiencia y no se recomienda por ahora
una cuarta dosis sólo en poblaciones
especiales y todavía no tenemos el
tiempo determinado para poderlo hacer
doctor para el cierre ya de esta
consulta varios medios internacionales
también han alertado sobre la aparición
del corona dengue cómo es posible que
estas dos enfermedades se unan qué
efectos tiene qué síntomas presenta qué
cuidados debemos tener qué se comenta en
la comunidad científica médica sobre
este tema
digamos que este es un hecho aún más
mediático que médico porque desde el
principio la pandemia hemos tenido
pacientes que tienen con infecciones es
decir un comodín gente que se compacta
con el coronavirus y con otras
infecciones también como puede ser como
con la influenza y el conocimiento que
lo importante es que el dengue es una
tenga que se transmite por vectores es
decir por la picadura del zancudo
mientras el córdoba 2 es una infección
respiratoria se pueden asociar en un
grupo de personas pero no quieres que
sea una nueva enfermedad o que vaya a
tener este carácter pandémico es en
algunas regiones hay que hacer algunas
precauciones un manejo médico especial
pero realmente no es nada para el armas
de santiago es mucho más mediato que
realmente médico el concepto de coronar
en muy oportuna esa aclaración el doctor
pérez un hecho más mediático que médico
pero sin embargo hay que mantener los
cuidados necesarios pero ya lo sabemos
entonces cómo funciona esta combinación
de estas dos enfermedades muchas gracias
doctor pérez por estar con nosotros aquí
en el programa en kobe 19 la semana en
américa
ahora como avanzado entonces la
vacunación en el continente americano en
esta oportunidad presentamos el
porcentaje de la población con dosis de
refuerzo ya aplicadas comenzamos en
brasil en donde el 25 6% ya han recibido
la dosis de refuerzo que dependiendo del
tipo de vacuna que hayan recibido puede
ser la segunda o una tercera dosis en
uruguay cerca del 53 8% de la población
ya tiene esta dosis de refuerzo y chile
alcanza el 68 por ciento de la población
en eeuu estados como el de nueva york-
levantarán la obligatoriedad del uso de
las mascarillas en lugares cerrados esto
mientras las cifras de casos descienden
también hay en eeuu hubo polémica en
torno a anthony fauci el asesor médico
jefe del presidente de eeuu que ha dicho
que será necesaria una cuarta dosis de
vacunación y que posiblemente la
pandemia de eeuu puede terminar pronto
vamos a nueva york- ahí está mamen sala
para darnos más detalles de lo que está
sucediendo allí ameneh gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa y
hablemos entonces de la eliminación de
la obligatoriedad del uso de las
mascarillas allí en nueva york' en los
espacios cerrados
sea el estado de nueva york dice adiós a
la mascarilla desde esta semana en el
interior de espacios públicos aunque va
a haber excepciones ya que todavía será
obligatoria en el transporte público en
las escuelas en los hospitales o en los
centros de ancianos así como en algunos
espacios privados que han decidido
seguir manteniendo el uso de esta
mascarilla como por ejemplo los teatros
de broadway que ya han dicho que será
obligatoria hasta por lo menos el 30 de
abril es una decisión que ha tomado la
gobernadora de nuevayork kathy hochul ha
justificado esta decisión en la caída en
picado que estamos viendo en las últimas
semanas en cuanto a nuevos contagios es
cierto que ha habido una disminución de
un 90 por ciento de contagios nuevos
desde mediados de enero que fue cuando
se alcanzó el último pico máximo en esta
pandemia provocado por la variante
omicron al estado de nueva york en esta
decisión se suman otros como por ejemplo
el de oregón nueva yersey con ética de
la web y california aseguran que ya
están listos para decir adiós a la
mascarilla a pesar de la preocupación
que ha despertado esta decisión entre
las autoridad sanitarias que consideran
que todavía es muy pronto para llevar a
cabo esta acción dicen que es verdad que
la situación está mejorando pero que las
cifras de hospitalizaciones y fallecidos
por kobe 19 todavía son muy altas una
decisión que han compartir que ha
compartido también el presidente de los
eeuu joe biden en una entrevista hecha
para un canal de televisión en este país
aseguraba que considera la decisión
prematura amén justamente quiero
preguntarle por la vacunación cómo está
avanzando en eeuu y le hago la pregunta
porque pronto allí en el estado de nueva
york se vence el plazo para que 4000
empleados municipales se vacunen o de lo
contrario perderán sus empleos
si aquí en eeuu la campaña de vacunación
avanza muy lentamente para que os hagáis
una idea tan sólo un 64% de la población
está completamente vacunada y un 75 8%
se ha puesto al menos una dosis aquí en
nueva york era obligatorio y tenían de
tiempo hasta el día de hoy 11 de febrero
para los trabajadores de las entidades
municipales estar vacunados de los
300.000 empleados públicos que hay en la
ciudad de nueva york el 95% se ha puesto
ya al menos una dosis pero todavía
quedan 40 4000 empleados que no se han
vacunado y se niegan a hacerlo esos son
los que según la norma implantada por el
anterior alcalde bill de blasio que
mantuvo el actual alcalde eric adams hoy
van a perder su puesto de trabajo el
alcalde de la ciudad de nueva york eric
adams asegura que ellos estos
trabajadores son los culpables de perder
su empleo porque han tenido tiempo
suficiente para vacunarse y también
suficientes advertencias de que tenían
que hacerlo por su parte el vocero de
los empleados que se niegan a vacunarse
asegura que esta decisión es injusta que
va a crear desempleo en conformidad
entre esos trabajadores que no quieren
vacunarse mamen y para terminar este
contacto esta conexión hablemos de esas
declaraciones de anthony fauci que es el
asesor médico y científico del
presidente de eeuu dijo que la pandemia
en eeuu puede terminar pronto pero que
será necesaria una cuarta dosis que
dicen allí sobre este tema
sí muy buenas noticias las que llegan
por parte del principal asesor médico de
la casa blanca el doctor anthony fauci
quien esta semana predijo el fin de la
fase aguda de esta pandemia aunque
también hizo hincapié en que quizás sea
necesaria una cuarta dosis para seguir
luchando contra el hobbit 19 el doctor
fauci asegura que todavía está en plan
temprano para hablar de mí en vez de
pandemia como han apuntado muchos países
europeos entre ellos españa quienes
aseguran que ya podríamos llamar a esta
pandemia endemia es decir una situación
controlada y predecible el doctor
anthony fauci cree que todavía es
temprano para eso y que quizá
necesitaremos una dosis de refuerzo cada
4 o 5 años para vencer al cob y
19a dicho que este virus ha llegado para
quedarse pero podemos aprender a
manejarlo y respecto a las restricciones
ha apuntado a que posiblemente casi
todas se levanten en este mismo año
aunque también ha recordado que puede
ser que los departamentos de salud
locales tengan que volver a reimplantar
algunas restricciones en caso de que
haya rebrotes
también muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de nueva york en eeuu
ahora demos un vistazo a las variantes
predominantes en diferentes países de
américa comenzamos en el norte en méxico
en donde el 100% de los casos reportados
en los últimos 28 días corresponde a la
variante omicron en el caribe en la isla
de jamaica la variante delta es la de
mayor incidencia con el 70 59% de los
casos le sigue la variante muy con el 26
como 89% alfa con el 0,84 por ciento y
otras alcanzan el 1 68% terminamos en
colombia allí en el 92 puntos 92 cova 89
por ciento de los casos reportados en
los últimos 28 días corresponden a la
variante omicron delta llega al 5,44 por
ciento mientras que otras variantes
corresponden al 1
67% de los casos
hablamos ahora de canadá allí continúan
las protestas contra las medidas
sanitarias por parte de los conductores
de camiones de acuerdo con la canadian
truck alliance una federación de
asociaciones provinciales de conductores
de camiones estiman que cerca del 90 por
ciento de los 1.200 transportistas
agremiados están ya vacunados contra el
kobe 19 esto genera un poco de confusión
por estas protestas las consecuencias a
nivel económico por las protestas y el
cierre de las vías ya comienzan a
pasarle factura a la economía canadiense
bailando cantando y tocando bocinas se
manifiesta el convoy de la libertad
desde hace dos semanas en oposición a
las medidas sanitarias y a los mandatos
de vacunas contra el kobe 19 en ottawa a
pesar de que la policía y los
funcionarios de esta ciudad canadiense
amenazan con multas detenciones
confiscación de vehículos e incluso con
la retirada de la custodia de sus hijos
también tienen
estos tipos no van a ir a ninguna parte
para que el gobierno puede aceptar el
hecho de que le quitaron la libertad a
la gente y se la devuelvan pacíficamente
y todos se van a casa todos están
felices o puedes traer la policía
antidisturbios como dijeron que lo
harían y eso terminaría muy feo
[Música]
en
me gusta ver y aquí
una encuesta realizada por la firma
canadiense leger 360 señaló que el 62
por ciento de los ciudadanos de este
país se opone a estas protestas mientras
que la firma de estadounidense abacus
mostró que el 67 por ciento está en
contra y que el 87 por ciento considera
que ha llegado el momento de que
abandonen su ocupación del centro de la
capital las protestas han afectado la
cadena de suministros en ambos lados de
la frontera entre eeuu y canadá y
suponen el desafío más reciente para el
sector automotriz
las consecuencias de estas acciones
están teniendo efectos nefastos están
impactando el comercio están
perjudicando puestos de trabajo están
amenazando nuestra economía y
obstruyendo nuestras comunidades estoy
enfocado en terminarlo espero que la
líder de la oposición mantenga su
postura actual y siga pidiendo el fin de
estos bloqueos
canadá ha inoculado con el esquema
completo a más del 80 por ciento de su
población total que cuenta con más de 38
millones de habitantes de acuerdo a un
estudio realizado por la organización
our world in data algunas provincias
canadienses como alberta quebec
saskatchewan la isla del príncipe
eduardo y nueva escocia han confirmado
que relajará las restricciones
sanitarias
vamos a conocer detalles de cómo está la
situación en colombia está con nosotros
en el estudio de france 24 maría clara
calle compañera de la redacción maría
clara bienvenida al programa gracias por
acompañarnos hoy con este reporte
especial de colombia vamos a empezar
hablando entonces del regreso presencial
a las clases en colombia porque los
menores de edad ya llevaban cerca de dos
semanas en las aulas en medio del pico
de la variante omicron que está
presentando colombia y que está
comenzando a salir apenas este país hola
santiago y gracias por tenerme aquí y
así es desde el comienzo del nuevo año
lectivo a finales de enero la directriz
nacional es que todos los colegios del
país retomen las clases presenciales y
con el 100% del aforo esto significa que
los 10 millones de estudiantes escolares
que hay en colombia ya deberían estar en
las aulas ese regreso ha sido escalonado
por ejemplo en bogotá a la capital en
2021 el 85% de la población escolar
alcanzó a volver a los salones pero no
todos han estado de acuerdo con este
retorno y es que la presencialidad
escolar coincidió con el cuarto pico de
la pandemia en el país cuando se estaban
entre 20.000 y 30.000 contagios diarios
una de las tasas más altas en toda la
emergencia sanitaria colombiana ante
esto el gremio sindical de docentes pecó
de pidió que se continuara en la
virtualidad al menos unas semanas más
pero el gobierno nacional mantuvo su
postura y respondió que la apuesta era
la vacunación de los niños y niñas
actualmente cerca del 60% de los menores
de 18 años se han vacunado contra el cob
y 19 según el ministerio de salud y de
ellos 4 millones son niños y niñas entre
los 3 y los 11 años que tienen al menos
la primera dosis es que ha sucedido
muchas cosas en colombia a lo largo de
estas primeras semanas del año 2022
maría clara no habíamos hecho un
análisis profundo de la situación en
colombia y ya que estamos hablando de
vacunación cuéntenos qué está pasando
precisamente con la inoculación de las
personas mayores de edad allí en este
país
bueno pues poco más de la mitad de los
colombianos ya tienen el esquema
completo contra el kobe 19 esto es 26
millones de personas el gobierno de iván
duque ha afirmado que ya tiene las
inoculaciones listas para vacunar con
todo el esquema a 40 millones de
personas
en el país ya los mayores de edad pueden
aplicarse la dosis de refuerzo el único
requisito es que la última inoculación
que tengan haya sido aplicada hace
cuatro meses o más hasta ahora en el
país se han aplicado seis millones de
dosis de refuerzo y españa tiene un
papel importante es que el país ibérico
le prometió a colombia la donación de
6,4 millones de dosis de facer a través
del mecanismo kóvacs de esas han llegado
2 millones incluyendo 1,1 millones que
llegaron hace una semana y un dato
adicional desde diciembre es obligatorio
tener la vacunación completa para poder
entrar a lugares como cines restaurantes
o discotecas para clara para el cierre
de este reporte sobre la situación en
colombia veamos entonces el panorama
general cómo están las cifras los
contagios el número de fallecidos que se
puede decir de la situación en colombia
bueno en todas las pandemias se han
confirmado casi 6 millones de casos de
coronavirus el país apenas atravesó su
peor momento de la pandemia y es que a
mediados de enero colombia reportó su
récord de contagios con más de 35.000 en
una sola jornada este pico ha ido
cayendo y actualmente los diagnósticos
positivos diarios rondan los 13 mil
de salud confirmó que la variante
omicron es la predominante ahora y como
ésta es más contagiosa el ministro de
salud fernando ruiz aseveró que la
propagación de este linaje contribuirá a
alcanzar la conocida inmunidad de rebaño
sin embargo advirtió que aunque los
casos ya están disminuyendo en las
próximas semanas se espera que haya un
periodo endémico precisamente porque la
cantidad de contagios económicos será un
poco más controlable por eso las
recomendaciones sin embargo es seguir
usando tapabocas que es obligatorio en
espacios públicos tanto al aire libre
como en recintos cerrados
marc aclara muchas gracias por este
reporte de la situación en colombia
gracias por acompañarnos aquí en el
estudio de kobe 19 la semana en américa
ahora demos un vistazo a otras noticias
relacionadas con la pandemia de kobe 19
destacadas en redes dos millones de
ciudadanos dominicanos ya tienen la
tercera dosis o dosis de refuerzo contra
el cob y 19 es por esto que los niños de
5 a 11 años comenzarán a ser vacunados
en los próximos días de acuerdo con el
esquema de inmunización dispuesto por el
ministerio de salud dominicano que
consiste en dos dosis de la vacuna si
novak con una diferencia de 28 días
entre y la segunda dosis
radioprogramas del perú publica el
ministerio de salud más de un millón de
niños ya recibieron la vacuna contra el
cob y 19 la inmunización de los menores
de edad en edades comprendidas entre los
5 y los 11 años en perú comenzó hace
poco más de dos meses antes del posible
regreso a las clases presenciales que
está previsto por el ministerio de salud
y de educación para finales del mes de
marzo que es cuando terminan las
vacaciones del verano austral allí en
perú y nuestros colegas de swissinfo
publican arribo de turistas argentinas
cae por segundo año consecutivo por
pandemia según el reporte la caída el
año pasado fue del 69 6% desde los ya
bajos niveles registrados en el 2020
cerca de 211 mil 100 turistas
extranjeros visitaron la argentina en
2021 según lo dice el instituto nacional
de estadística y censos de ese país
suramericano
y lo hemos dicho varias veces en este
programa chile ha sido el líder en la
región en cuanto a la vacunación también
en cuanto a la inoculación de las dosis
de refuerzo o tercera o cuarta dosis
dependiendo del caso junto con israel
pero los casos de fallecidos y las
hospitalizaciones van en aumento en ese
país suramericano a qué se debe esta
situación se lo vamos a preguntar
entonces a patricia luna en la ciudad de
santiago vamos a preguntarle entonces
allí en la capital chilena
cómo va avanzando esta cuarta vacunación
esta cuarta dosis para las personas
mayores de 55 años en todo el territorio
chileno patricio
hola santiago es el primer presidente
del gobierno chileno sebastián piñera
daba inicio oficial al proceso de
vacunación masiva para la cuarta dosis
para mayores de 55 años que hubieran
recibido su tercera dosis hasta agosto
de 2021 al vacunarse el mismo y recibir
en persona esta cuarta dosis de la
vacuna un proceso que ya se había
iniciado el pasado 10 de enero con
personal prioritario del personal de
salud y también personas
inmunodeprimidas y que continuará a
partir del próximo 7 de marzo cuando
todas las personas mayores de 18 años
también podrán acceder a esta cuarta
dosis de la vacuna que se justifica
según un comunicado de presidencia
porque se ha comprobado científicamente
que la eficacia de las vacunas disminuye
a lo largo del tiempo tanto en el caso
de los contagios como en los casos más
serios contra la cob y hasta el jueves
se habían administrado 440 mil dosis de
esta cuarta dosis de la vacuna que sitúa
a chile entre
líder en américa latina en la región y
también como uno de los primeros países
en el mundo en administrar esta cuarta
dosis patricia cómo está la situación en
torno a las restricciones hago la
pregunta porque también en chile está
por terminar el receso de las vacaciones
de verano y los estudiantes van a
regresar a las aulas y eso también
llevará un poco al regreso a la
normalidad en la dinámica del país que
dicen allí
con la llegada de la variante o micro en
responsable del 90 de los casos
registrados en las últimas semanas chile
vive uno de los peores momentos de la
pandemia en cuanto al número de
contagios por ejemplo las últimas 24
horas se registraban más de 38 mil 400
contagios la cifra más alta de toda la
pandemia muy por encima de los 9.000
casos máximos que se habían registrado
en oleadas anteriores como la de abril
de 2021 en los últimos días los casos
reportados a diario han superado en la
barrera de los 30.000 una barrera que
muestra también las dificultades para
acceder a las pruebas pcr y las pruebas
de antígenos con algunos alcaldes de
comunas de santiago y los alrededores
denunciando una escasez de stock algo
que es desmentido por el ministro de
salud enrique parís sin embargo la
realidad es que es cada vez más difícil
acceder a estas pruebas pcr y de
antígenos las colas son más largas y
todas las autoridades coinciden en
señalar que las cifras reportadas
podrían ser un su reporte de lo que está
ocurriendo realmente que hay más casos
de los que dicen las cifras oficiales
como también pasó en otros en europa con
esta oleada de omicron en total son más
de 25 millones de chilenos los que ya se
han contagiado desde el inicio de la
pandemia en una semana en la que también
se supera el umbral de una triste cifra
más de 40.000 personas han fallecido en
chile en concreto 40
1.370 según las últimas cifras oficiales
a consecuencia del coronavirus patricia
precisamente quería preguntarle por las
cifras porque en los últimos días pese a
la alta vacunación que tiene este país
suramericano están experimentando un
incremento en el número de personas
hospitalizadas en salas de cuidado
intensivo y también hay un incremento en
el número de personas fallecidas son
cifras que venían en descenso que
parecían estar estables que es lo que
está sucediendo entonces allí
pues con una positividad
como la última reportada del casi el 26
era de esperar también que estas cifras
se tradujeran en un mayor ingreso en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos que en
el caso de chiles de un 64% el
incremento en el último mes en la
actualidad y 766 personas ingresadas en
las unidades de cuidados intensivos en
su mayoría personas mayores de 55 años
que no habían recibido ningún tipo de
vacuna o que habían recibido una de las
22 dosis necesarias para completar su
sistema de inoculación esto en un país
que tiene una alta tasa de vacunación
según las últimas cifras oficiales de la
población que puede recibir vacunas ya
se ha vacunado casi un 93 por ciento de
la misma una cifra que entre los niños
de 3 a 17 años es de un 77% los que
completaron sus sistemas de inoculación
recordemos que en chile los niños se
pueden vacunar a partir de los 3 años
esta tasa de vacunación también sitúa a
chile como líder uno de los líderes en
américa latina y también
entre la población mundial en cuanto a
su alta tasa de vacunación patricia
muchas gracias por este reporte desde la
ciudad de santiago una soledad de
calurosa ciudad de santiago a esta hora
brevemente les presentamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana en
nuestro continente brevemente les cuento
que en honduras más de 22.000 personas
han fallecido por cuenta del cob y 19
desde el 2020 lo que supone el doble de
las cifras oficiales de decesos este
anuncio lo hizo el presidente de la
asociación de funerarias de honduras
edwin lanza de ser confirmada esto
evidenciaría que la situación en
honduras es más difícil de lo que dicen
las autoridades brevemente también les
cuento que han cambiado los requisitos
de ingreso a territorio ecuatoriano por
vía aérea ya no será necesario presentar
un resultado negativo de una prueba pcr
o de antígenos sólo será necesario
presentar el certificado de vacunación y
tener el esquema completo de vacunación
y la vicepresidenta ejecutiva de
venezuela del cid rodríguez pidió a la
organización mundial de la salud mejor
dar el acceso a las vacunas contra el
joven 19 por parte de los países de
bajos recursos económicos en este
encuentro con el director de la omct
edrosa among ebre jesús rodríguez la
vicepresidenta reconoció la efectividad
de la vacuna rusa sputnik de la vacuna
china scinopharm y la vacuna cubana
aldana que son aplicadas entre la
población de venezuela
y con esto llegamos al final de nuestro
programa nos vemos la próxima semana con
un resumen de noticias aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa sigan cuidando sed
el coronavirus la emergencia persiste en
el mundo entero nos vemos la próxima
semana hasta entonces
[Música]